the Home Secretary joins us now from
Westminster Priti Patel really good to
see this morning thanks for being with
us I wonder if we might start on a topic
that I'm sure will be concerning you
will be concerning at numerous members
of the British public the corona virus
outbreak emanating from China in simple
terms it is just a matter of time isn't
it until we have a case of corona virus
here in the UK well that's why the
government has taken all the precautions
and the right measures it's obviously
across government this is a cross
government effort we're working with the
World Health Organization public health
England my colleague Matt Hancock
chaired Cobra on Friday because rightly
we have concerns we want to protect
British citizens we have concerns
obviously in terms of the impact of this
virus and so it's right that we are
working across government as I've said
with the Department of Health but also
public health England with our border
force officers as well to ensure that we
do our utmost to keep the British public
safe currently the advice for the ROM
the government for those who are in
China in the affected areas is to get
out if they can how are they supposed to
do that given that all the transport
hubs of closed-down well I think first
of all we have to just be very mindful
of the fact that there have been flights
and those that the area has been closed
down only just recently the happy
flights to and from China and obviously
we are working now public health England
have their own hub now at Heathrow
Airport so this is all not just about
the particular location but this virus
has spread obviously to other locations
within China and to the region so it's
important that we ensure that we share
data we share information in terms of
passengers and travelers that's
something that we are doing obviously
this is a fast-moving situation and
there's work taking place in government
right now every day we're watching the
situation we're working as I've said
with the World Health Organisation
authorities in China to to assess how we
can practically give assistance but also
what are the measures we will have to
undertake and the government's working
on that right now but the reason the
reason I asked the question Home
Secretary is that it's being reported by
both the Sun and the mail that the
government is currently planning airlift
sending at creating an air bridge
between China and the UK to get
Britain's home is that accurate
well look we're looking at all options
I'm not
comment specifically on newspaper
stories but it's right that we look at
all options and that's exactly what the
government is doing right now just in
terms of those who returned to the
United Kingdom from the affected areas
before the government got on the front
foot so to speak what efforts are being
made to find them and to ensure that
they are not carrying the violence well
there are many efforts being made and
this is actually where border Falls
provides information to public health
England in terms of passengers that have
travelled to and from the error and so
they are actually contacting people and
reaching out to them and providing
screening and testing and that that is
fine that is in hand and that is taking
place but I think quite frankly right
now in light of the urgency of the
situation and rightly so we are working
with the Chinese authorities the World
Health Organization public health
England to look at actually what is
going on and to ensure that we are doing
our utmost to stop the virus from coming
to the United Kingdom and obviously
becoming a widespread problem but just
as things turn to them secretary as of
this point the information that you have
available to you no confirmed cases also
on the virus
that's absolutely right fantastic thank
you and I wonder in this week of of
brexit we're coming out of the European
Union on well at one minute past 11:00
on the 31st and do you see this as a as
a moment to be marked or a moment to be
celebrated well I think it is an
occasion there's no doubt about that for
our country you know three years since
we had the referendum and after a lot of
political discourse discussion and
heated debates as well this is a very
significant moment for our country but I
actually think we mark the occasion yes
by reflecting on the referendum the last
three years but we should also look to
the future now in an incredibly positive
way well we can look at how we can heal
divisions that have taken place it is a
fact that have been divisions over
recent years and times are brexit and I
withdraw from the European Union but we
have to recognize now that there is
tremendous opportunity now for our
country whether it comes to trade
immigration the fact that we'll be
taking back control of our laws will be
an independent country we won't be a
rule taker and I think for the whole of
the United
you know we are leaving the EU as one
United Kingdom this is an extraordinary
moment for us a big opportunity to look
at how post the general election we can
bring new opportunities to every part
every corner every region of the United
Kingdom and bring this government's
agenda of levelling up when it comes to
opportunity to people to future
prospects when it comes to skills
infrastructure to each part of the
country that is something that we are
excited about and absolutely determined
to deliver from CC I wonder if you might
be able to help me out miss Patel and be
the first kind of cabinet minister to
concede that the 31st of January is is
not the end it is not even the beginning
of the end but perhaps the end of the
beginning I mean there's still a country
mile to go in terms of negotiating
free-trade agreements and so on before
we can see really that we have left the
European Union well I think first of all
we are leaving so Neil that is a fact
on Friday and by leaving we will be
taking control of our laws our borders
our money that is a very very
significant moment we will stop being a
rule taker we'll be ending free movement
through the legislation that I will be
bringing through Parliament and it is a
fact of course we will have an
opportunity now we'll have many
opportunities now to enter negotiations
to secure a Canada style free trade
agreement with our partners and friends
in the European Union the political
declaration has set that out very
clearly yes we are leaving on Friday yes
we will have new opportunities yes
there'll be new negotiations new discove
discussions with our partners and our
friends in the EU but also around the
world whether it's the US or Asia other
countries that work has already started
place and that is something that would
be tremendously exciting not just for
our nation but I think for the country
and for many other countries around the
world who we will be having a different
dialogue with and a different
relationship going forward and there is
as much as others particularly during
the cabinet table we'll be looking to
the extent to which we as a country
diverge from the European Union what is
your view on all of this there seems to
be some conflicting messages from
government over the past couple of weeks
do we remain in close alignment with the
European Union or is this the time to
to make a break for it no there is no
disagreement in government at all we are
clear
we are leaving we'll be taking back
control of our laws our money our
borders and in terms of average from the
constitutional divergence
let's be very clear about this we intend
to we're not having alignment we will be
diverging we want to take control of our
laws money our borders and to do that
will be we will not be rule takers kneel
we will be setting our own laws and that
is a fundamental feature of leaving the
European Union and as I've said already
in the political declaration
specifically to the relationship between
the UK and the EU we've set out the
direction of travel already yes
negotiations but we've been very clear
in terms of that relationship we want to
Canada style free-trade arrangement and
we want to have you know we want to
achieve those shared aims as outlined in
the political so where will the
divergence take place what look that's
we're about to I'm not going to
speculate now we're about to enter a
negotiation and this isn't about
identify particular areas we've been
clear that when it comes to our
agricultural policy we all have
independence we've been clear when it
comes to our immigration policy we're
taking back control have our own
immigration policies will have a
points-based system one that the British
government is in charge of these are the
fundamental tenants of leaving the EU
we've been very clear about that in the
very week of course that the withdraw
bill the act was passed through
Parliament we are leaving
we're going to stop being a rule taker
and we will now have newfound freedoms
where we can set out our own course our
own path for independence and that also
means divergence non Alliance across a
range of areas through a range of
negotiations that we'll be entering I
mean you mentioned immigration and being
able to control the numbers and we've
had Boris Johnson on the program making
it clear that the numbers will come down
again something that seems a little
confused you might be able to clarify
that 30,000 pound minimum wage for
people coming into the country has that
requirement been scrapped well we will
be following the guidance on the
migration Advisory Committee and I'm not
going to prejudge that we've been pretty
much reviewed oh no I'm not giving you
my view because I commercial or eMac I
commissioned the Mac towards the end of
last year
it's right that the Mac you by the way
are reporting this week in terms of the
points based system caps and numbers and
how we will be going about the points
based system it is right that I look at
what they're proposing and it's right
there I work with them and in addition
to that we have been abundantly clear in
the run-up to the election after the
election in our manifesto and through
the legislation that we'll be bringing
forward through the immigration bill
when it comes forth that we are
absolutely determined to change the
immigration system and the complexity of
the immigration system have simpler
rules have a points-based system where
we can absolutely have people that bring
the right skills for our labor market
meet the right kind of labor market test
but also bring the right kind of skills
that we need in our country promoting
the brightest and the best while at the
same time supporting our public services
through initiatives such as the NHS visa
that I announced a few months ago and
that is exactly the type of visa regime
that we'll be bringing forward because
it's important our economy it supports
our labor market and it supports our
public services why do we want
immigration numbers to come down I mean
it strikes me your own personal
remarkable story your parents you know
fleeing idea mean coming here to the
United Kingdom and just a couple it a
few day short decades later here you are
as Home Secretary it strikes me that the
pretty Patel's story makes a rather good
case for continued immigration perhaps
even at the levels that we are now we
know that immigrants are net
contributors to the economy well we know
also that people that come to our
country with the right skills obviously
contribute in many ways this isn't about
comparing what our plans and intentions
are right now with a points-based system
with previous histories on to
immigration the fact of the matter is
we're leaving the European Union which
means free movement will end and that
also means we'll be able to control the
level of unskilled migration that has
come to the United Kingdom and quite
frankly that has come to the United
Kingdom in many ways that yes may have
contributed and has contributed to the
economic growth of our nation but also
now puts a spotlight on the type of
skills that we need to grow our labor
market to be a successful economy going
forward to continue on our economic
but also to make sure yes we have to
write skills but that British businesses
as well grow and invest in the British
public - they have been far too reliant
on low-skilled and quite frankly chief
labour from the EU and we want to end
that we think it's about time that
businesses started to invest in people
across the whole of the United Kingdom
that they join with us on our agenda to
level up the skills the infrastructure
the economic growth across all our
regions promote growth across the whole
of the United Kingdom and that is one of
the key opportunities that we have when
we leave the EU through the immigration
system the points-based system that we
will be bringing yes supporting the
brightest and the best but also
encouraging British industry to do more
to invest in capital in people in human
capital and the skills that our country
and our economy needs in the long run
something in your to-do list at the
moment while we strange question this
for me to ask are you pretty Patel on
the warpath right now because that's
this the Sunday Times is saying this
morning it says that you are fitting
about the fact that Whitehall officials
have bounced the Prime Minister into
letting while we're being billed
non-core parts of the 5g system how
accurate is that well Neil that's not
accurate and you shouldn't take too
literally what you are reading the
Sunday newspapers if I may say so
look my role is very much to protect the
national security of our country and
that also includes intelligence services
and communications as well we are having
discussions and rightly so those
discussions remain at the National
Security Council level and within
cabinet level and of course we will have
those discussions will have them
privately and I'm not going to comment
on speculation in newspapers these are
very important discussions we will
continue and I will continue to work to
and promote the national security of our
nation and our intelligence services and
also our networks we don't exist in a
vacuum on this particular topic with an
American delegation in tone the other
week suggesting that it would be nothing
short of madness to let huawei in I mean
are they wrong well look I should also
just add Neal's that you know we are
part of the five eyes community we work
we work very closely
our five eyes partners are American
friends and allies who are part of that
as well
and we share a lot of information and we
all share our own views based on facts
data and intelligence and that
cooperation and that way of working it
will absolutely continue because they're
telling you not to lo while we in on the
5g system and it strikes me that as
things stand it remains a possibility
well we base all our judgments we base
all our decisions on information that we
look together will you review across
government that is what we're doing
right now Neil so I'm not going to give
a view on what our counterparts are
saying or give a view in terms of some
of the speculation that has been written
about in our newspapers tell me a little
bit about your safe streets initiative
the government obviously fought the
general election at promising additional
police numbers trying to to claw back a
little bit on the on what seems over the
past few years to seem to be in a
significant spike in violent crime
particularly here in the capital tell us
a little bit about this well first of
all we have announced this week the
highest amount of money and resource
going into policing in over a decade and
that's over 1.1 billion pounds and our
police forces are funded to up to 15
billion pounds but this safer streets
initiative is something actually that I
announced last October at our party
conference and this is a initiative very
specific it's a 25 million pound
initiative on top of the resources that
we're already in the the resources were
given to police forces for them to
specifically target the type of crimes
that we see in our communities far too
often
so that's burglary that's theft the type
of crimes that really have a significant
impact upon the victims of car crimes
and burglaries and we want to resource
our police forces particularly in high
crime areas where we see far too much of
this activity to ensure that they can
pursue the perpetrators of these crimes
the support victims but also do much
more within the local communities to
prevent such crimes from happening so
anything ranging from greater street
lighting CCTV
work within the community as well in
terms of prevention and aware
this is really part of the repertoire of
tools that we are now given our police
forces around the country on crime
prevention but also given them the tools
and resources and the equipment and the
powers that they need to tackle crime in
a way in which they've not been able to
previously before because the nature of
crime is changing we see much more in
terms of serious violence but we see far
too much at this type of crime burglary
theft car theft the type of crime really
that is quite corrosive across our towns
and our villages and our communities
around the country
Priti Patel you have a very busy week
ahead of your arm sure so we'll let you
get on with that thanks very much for
joining us thank you Neal